We're talking about ancient human hearing!
We're talking!! oh forget it.
listeners and friends
We've spent a lot of time on DNews talking
about language and the power of spitting flow
atcha, but no matter how sick your flow, if
we hadn't evolved hearing, it would be lost
on you.
Hearing is one of our essential traits, and
according to a study from a Jan 2006 issue
of Nature we got our auditory adroitness from
fish gills!
Our ears have tiny bones which translate waves
of energy pushing through the air from wave
energy to mechanical energy, then fluid energy,
before conversion to chemical signals for
processing in the brain.
But, 370 million years ago, a fish called
Eusthenopteron [Yoos-then-opter-on], had a
small bone which had a kink that blocked the
gill opening, and its descendant, Panderichthys
[Pander-ick-this] had a slightly wider version
of that bone, called a spiracle.
Spiracles allow the fish to breathe air above
the surface while it remains underwater (which
in itself is incredible), but scientists think
the spiracle is the missing link between fish
gills and land-animal hearing!
There are, of course, a number of evolutionary
steps in-between; for example, the hyomandibular
[hi-oh-mandib-u-lar] bone which became the
stapes -- a stirrup-shaped bone in the middle
ear -- evolved from a bone that used to brace
the lower jaw of sharks and early jawed fishes.
Because of these tiny bones and slow adaptations,
we slowly adapted our own hearing.
According to an old study from the Journal
of the Acoustical Society of America: generally
speaking, mammals have larger audible fields
than birds and reptiles, mostly because of
our ability to hear higher frequencies thanks
to adaptations of the middle ear around 40
million years ago in the Eocene era.
Human hearing isn't the best in the natural
world, but it's not the worst either.
Thanks to our close-set ears, we can hear
high-frequency sounds; a great adaptation
for hearing brief high-frequency noises -- like
the rustles made by predators in the woods.
Just a guess.
As time wore on we eventually got to the 2.1-million-year-old
Australopithecus Africanus, an ancient human
ancestor.
This hominin had an earlier version of our
hearing systems, and a new study in September
2015's Science Advances, scanned the skulls
of this and Paranthropus robustus and used
the scans to reconstruct a computer model
of early human ears.
Turns out, Australopithecus' and Paranthropus'
physiologies allowed them to hear very differently
than modern humans.
Back then, we were more sensitive to Ts, Ks,
Fs and Ss in the 1 to 3 kHz range, because
savannahs don't have things for sound to bounce
off of!
The researchers think they would have been
able to hear these hard consonant sounds short-range
across open areas, which makes sense because
these ancient humans were all about that savannah
life.
On top of that, Australopithecus and Paranthropus
were better at 1-3kHz than we humans OR our
primate cousins are now.
By comparison, today, modern humans speak
in the 1kHz to 6kHz range, something these
ancient humans wouldn't have been good at
at all.
A 2011 study in the journal Science, used
a mathematical model to trace DNA evidence
of human migration and language development,
and found verbal communication did likely
originate in Africa; probably in the form
of click language.
Hard consonant languages could be 100,000
years old!
What if, as we left the forests and savannahs
of Africa, our hearing changed too, and we
evolved language to match that evolution!
That would explain why we speak in that 1-6
range today, but these ancient people use
the click languages and spoke in hard consonants,
because it was easier to hear.
Science is still trying to figure this out,
but what do you think?